what's up guys so as you guys already
know many PC components are very
overpriced right now such as graphics
cards RAM and even SSDs various factors
such as cryptocurrency mining the NAND
flash shortage and even a huge demand
for PC parts due to many new PC gamers
and leases of rice and Conflict have
contributed to huge increase in PC part
prices if you guys are interested and
whether I think you should buy a
prebuilt or build a PC then make sure to
check my video on that I also have
videos on what I think GPU and ram
prices will go down so make sure to
check those out too if you're interested
so in this video I'm going to be going
through every level of GPU and tell you
guys what I think is the best pre-built
on the market for that GPU so let's get
started first there is the ultra budget
PC this is a PC with the gtx 1050 and in
my opinion this is a killer deal usually
I would only recommend pcs with an SSD
however this is the entry-level and this
is a really great deal
the Asus PC comes with the gtx 1050
Intel i5 7400 CPU one terabyte hard
drive and eight gigabytes of ddr4 memory
it comes in at five hundred and fifty
dollars and I think it's a great value
by and this would be very hard to be in
price it with a custom build next up the
entry-level PC for the RX 560 is in my
opinion even better it comes at the
risin 5 1408 gigabytes of ram one
terabyte hard drive the RX 560 is pretty
much identical to attend 50 and in this
case it is even cheaper at 504 dollars
it's a very good deal and again would be
difficult to beat in price with the
constant PC next if you're looking at
the gtx 1050 TI then here's one for
right at $600 this pc only has the intel
pentium g 4600 but if you aim to use
this pc mainly for gaming then this is
well enough to handle that 1050 TI this
pc also comes with 8 gigabytes of ram
and one terabyte hard drive next for the
red side a PC with the RX 570 this PC
comes in at $650 and has the authorized
at 5 to 1400
a gigabytes of ddr4 ram and one terabyte
hard drive this pc is only fifty dollars
more than last one but I think it will
deliver significantly superior
performance razor rising 514 hundred is
much better than the Pentium and the 570
is better than a 1050 Ti so if we have
the cache and strongly recommend to get
this one over the last one all the other
graphics cards from AMD are a very
overpriced right now so I am only going
to be covering Nvidia from now on so for
the GTX 1063 gigabyte card this HP
Pavillion comes in at $750 and it comes
equipped with an Intel i5 7408 you buy
some ddr4 ram and a one terabyte hard
drive this next PC is in my opinion this
sweet spot this Alienware PC comes in at
950 dollars and has 16 gigabytes of ddr4
Ram I 580 400 one terabyte of hard drive
space and of course the gtx 1066 by
gigabyte card now on the pcs covered
will cost over $1000 I believe that a PC
in this range should have an SSD and at
least 16 gigabytes of RAM so everything
else on this list will have those
specifications I'm going to include a
few more builds with the gtx 1066 minute
gigabyte card but this cart is a quite
versatile and does make sense to put it
with an i7 and rhymes and seven so going
back to 1063 gigabyte card here is a abs
pc at $1,100 that has an Intel i7 7700
16 gigabytes of ddr4 ram 140 gigabyte
SSD and a one terabyte hard drive next
onto the GTX 1066 combined card here is
another ABS PC fasted gtx 1066 nearby
card Intel i7 7700 K 16 gigabytes of
ddr4 ram 128 gigabytes of an SSD space
and a one terabyte hard drive finally
here is the max I would spend on a gtx
1066 qi card this pc is packed with
power and speed
it comes in at $1,400 has the best
gaming cpu on the market the intel i7
8700 k
one pair of my hard drive 16 gigabytes
of RAM and 240 gigabyte SSD if you want
this same pc with some flair for just
$30 more here is a PC from ibuypower
which is same specs inside but a much
sleeker body and even has liquid cooling
honestly I think the iBUYPOWER looks so
much better I would definitely take the
IFI power over the ABS battle box next
onto premium 1070 bills this abs PC
comes in at 1350 dollars has an i7 7716
gigabytes of RAM 150 gigabyte SSD and a
one terabyte hard drive this pc is
really a very powerful gaming pc for its
price next up is a very powerful PC that
comes the i7 8700 k 16 gigabytes of ram
156 gigabyte nvme SSD one terabyte hard
drive and this is probably the end of
the mid-range pcs next onto 1080 pcs
here is an absolutely crazy deal this
abs PC comes with an i7 7716 gigabytes
of RAM 250 gigabytes of ICG storage 1
terabyte hard drive and this only $1400
getting a 1080p C for this price is
really quite good this next 10 a PC has
16 gigabytes of RAM the ice and it is a
motorcade 250 gigabyte gigabytes of nvme
SSD space 1 pair my hard drive and it
comes in at 8200 others if you care
about how it looks then here is a much
better looking PC for only $20 more with
the same specs and liquid cooling I
would definitely choose this over one
over the previous one visit looks so
much better for about the same price
next onto the best GPU available the G
takes 1080p on this PC comes in at
eighteen hundred and eighty dollars and
it is a much superior to building it
yourself if you built this yourself
it would cost even 500 to 700 dollars
more so this is a really good deal this
PC has the gtx 980ti i 787 okay 16
gigabytes of ram 240 gigabyte SSD and a
one terabyte hard drive anything above
this is in my opinion overpriced so I am
going to stop right there well guys did
I miss out on any crazy deals out there
for pre-built pcs make sure to post
those in the comments below I do read
all my comments I am curious as to what
you guys think that's all I have for you
guys this time if you like this video
make sure to let put a like on this
video if you guys loved it and would
like to see more videos just like this
they make sure you hit that subscribe
button and bail notification so that
you're notified whenever I post a new
video but that's all I have for you guys
this time and until the next video bye